well you know there is speculation and
it may be a little more than speculation
out that went that infants are
synesthetes and synesthesia is simply a
crossing of two senses almost like it's
like a translation of one sense into
another famous examples are people who
see numbers as colors every number has a
distinct color synesthetes don't agree
on which color but when they 7 for
example for some people is always green
I do not have that kind of synesthesia
but in a way I think many of us that
have that when we read you know when I
read a book I'm always seeing the people
i'm making mental images to accompany it
so that i'm translating you know the the
sight of those little-little you know
characters on the page into visual
images that i can take with man keep I
was rather amused to read you know
during my research for this book about
something called mirror touch
synesthesia and saying to myself well I
have that and so that is when people
look at someone or something is
happening to another person say you look
at someone being slapped on the arm and
then the the mirror touch synesthete has
a sensation in the arm not the same as
being slapped at least not in my case at
all but there is a kind of mirroring
experience so that the visual looking
becomes the tactile impression in the
body and I think you see again going
back to behavior ism and talk of this
before brain scans and before recent
research into the brain people were very
reluctant to
do any studies about synesthesia because
it just seemed so wacky and so that's
what happens once researchers have some
kind of hypothesis about neural networks
in the brain and maybe that infants are
all synesthetes and that these as the
brain develops as its plasticity
continues most people lose that crossing
over from one sense to the other and
some people don't they retain it